This episode is brought to you by Redfin. You're listening to a podcast, which means you're probably multitasking, maybe even scrolling home listings on Redfin, saving homes without expecting to get them. But Redfin isn't just built for endless browsing. It's built to help you find and own a home. With agents who close twice as many deals, when you find the one, you've got a real shot at getting it. Get started at Redfin.com. Own the dream.
本期节目由 Redfin 赞助播出。你正在收听播客，这意味着你可能正在一心多用，甚至可能正在 Redfin 上浏览房源，收藏那些你并不指望能买到的房子。但 Redfin 不仅仅是为了让你无休止地浏览而设计的，它是为了帮助你找到并拥有一个家。我们的经纪人成交量是其他人的两倍，当你找到心仪的房子时，你就有很大的机会将其收入囊中。请访问 Redfin.com 开始你的旅程。拥有梦想。
Hello, this is Caitlin Luna, host. of Speaking of Psychology. This podcast was recorded live during the 2018 APA convention in San Francisco. It's about the dark side of screen time. Enjoy. I'm joined by Dr. Adam Alter, a New York Times bestselling author and psychologist. His most recent book explores the dark sides of screen time and how our devices are affecting our well-being and happiness. Dr. Alter is also an associate professor of marketing at New York University, and his research is about judgment and decision-making and social psychology. Welcome, Dr. Alter. Thanks to having me.
你好，我是《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology）的主持人凯特琳·卢纳。本期播客是在旧金山举行的 2018 年美国心理学会（APA）年会上现场录制的。主题是关于屏幕时间的阴暗面。希望你喜欢。今天和我在一起的是《纽约时报》畅销书作家、心理学家亚当·奥尔特博士。他最近的一本书探讨了屏幕时间的阴暗面，以及我们的设备如何影响我们的幸福感和快乐。奥尔特博士还是纽约大学的市场营销学副教授，他的研究领域是判断与决策以及社会心理学。欢迎你，奥尔特博士。谢谢邀请。
Happy to have you here today. So I watched a TED talk of yours where you were talking about between 2007 and 2017 about all the time in our daily lives. So taking out time for sleeping, work, commuting, eating, that sort of thing, we have this precious few hours of our personal time. And you noted that in those 10 years, the amount of personal time we spend on a screen time rose exponentially. Can you explain more about that? Yeah, so we don't have that many hours in the day when we aren't doing things like working,
很高兴你今天能来。我看了你的一场 TED 演讲，你在演讲中谈到了 2007 年到 2017 年间我们日常生活中的时间分配。除去睡觉、工作、通勤、吃饭等必要时间，我们剩下的个人时间少得可怜。你指出，在这十年里，我们花在屏幕上的个人时间呈指数级增长。你能详细解释一下吗？好的，我们一天中除了工作、
sleeping, eating, taking care of other people, certain things that are kind of fixed, and then that leaves this period of a few hours that's open to us. It's discretionary, it's personal time. And we've always spent some of that time as a population on screens because we've watched TV for many decades. And so in 2007, before the introduction of the first generation of the iPhone, we spent about 30, or 40% of that time on TV, on screens, and to some extent on computers as well. But with the introduction of the iPhone in 07 and the iPad in 2010, there was a huge rise in the adoption of other kinds of more portable screens. And as a result, today, there's only
睡觉、吃饭、照顾他人等一些相对固定的事情外，并没有太多空闲时间，剩下的那几个小时就是我们可以自由支配的个人时间。作为一个群体，我们一直以来都会花一些时间在屏幕上，因为我们看电视已经几十年了。所以，在 2007 年第一代 iPhone 推出之前，我们大约 30% 到 40% 的时间花在电视、屏幕以及某种程度上的电脑上。但随着 2007 年 iPhone 和 2010 年 iPad 的推出，其他便携式屏幕的普及率大幅上升。结果就是，今天我们几乎
a very, very tiny sliver of time that's available to us when we're not in front of some form of screen. And on average, it's less than half an hour for most people. So into that half an hour now, we're trying to cram face-to-face time with loved ones, with friends, and exercise, any hobbies, any things that we do that make us human and individual and different from other people. And it's a lot to ask of half an hour of our day. It's obviously about a 50th of the day. It's not a lot of time. So since the most flexible thing in that day is the time we spend on our screens, the argument is perhaps we should try to spend a bit less of that time on screens. So why are screens so irresistible to us that we're using up all that time
没有多少时间是不面对屏幕的。平均而言，大多数人每天剩下的空闲时间不到半小时。现在，我们试图在这半小时里挤进与亲人、朋友面对面交流的时间，还要锻炼、培养爱好，做任何让我们成为人类、成为个体、与众不同的事情。要求这半小时承载这么多内容确实太难了。这显然只占一天时间的五十分之一，时间并不多。既然一天中最灵活的部分就是我们花在屏幕上的时间，那么论点就是，也许我们应该尝试减少在屏幕上花费的时间。那么，为什么屏幕对我们如此具有吸引力，以至于我们耗尽了所有
that we could be doing other things? Yeah, it's such a big question. And it was such a big question that I ended up writing hundreds of pages on it. The simple answer is that there are a number of hooks that are embedded in the programs we use on screens that make them very difficult to resist. So the people who design these programs have access to huge amounts of data. They don't even have to be great psychologists to understand the way different features influence us because all they have to do is throw a thousand different variations at the wall and see which one sticks the best and then they use that one. If you iterate that process over and over again, as you've seen as platforms like Facebook have evolved over the years.
本可以做其他事情的时间呢？这是一个非常宏大的问题。正因为这个问题太大，我最终为此写了几百页的内容。简单的回答是，我们使用的屏幕程序中嵌入了许多让人难以抗拒的“钩子”。设计这些程序的人拥有海量的数据。他们甚至不需要成为伟大的心理学家就能理解不同的功能是如何影响我们的，因为他们只需要把一千种不同的变体扔到墙上，看看哪一种效果最好，然后就使用那一种。如果你一遍又一遍地重复这个过程，就像你看到的 Facebook 等平台这些年来的演变一样。
The version we're using today is a sort of weaponized version that has so many little hooks embedded that once we start using it, it's very hard for us to stop. So part of what they do is at a very narrow sort of individual level, as we're using them, we're getting a lot of feedback cues that keep us hooked. We set up a lot of goals, for example, getting a certain number of likes or having a certain number of followers that keep us hooked. But also there's something much more macro and sociological. about the experience that especially for younger people it's very different to have a full
我们今天使用的版本是一种经过“武器化”的版本，它嵌入了太多的小钩子，一旦我们开始使用，就很难停下来。所以，他们所做的一部分工作是在非常狭窄的个人层面进行的，当我们使用它们时，我们会得到很多让我们上瘾的反馈信号。例如，我们设定了很多目标，比如获得一定数量的点赞或拥有一定数量的粉丝，这些都会让我们上瘾。但除此之外，还有一些更宏观、更社会学层面的东西，
rich social life now without being to some extent involved in in the platforms that everyone else seems to be using so when you combine the psychology and the sociology of the whole experience it just becomes very difficult to live a mainstream life today where you completely disengage or even spend less than a good few hours a day on your screens actually you asked the question earlier the average is now four hours a day for the average American adult and for kids and teens who use screens it's up to six. Wow. Yeah. It's very gentle. I know myself it's challenging and so for everyone out there it is. And you you've talked in your book about how the tech giants of the world, they limit screen time for their children. So what does that tell us? Yeah, I think that's fascinating.
尤其是对于年轻人来说，如果不在某种程度上参与每个人似乎都在使用的平台，就很难拥有一个完整、丰富的社交生活。所以，当你把整个体验的心理学和社会学结合起来时，在今天过一种主流生活，完全脱离屏幕，或者每天在屏幕上花费的时间少于几个小时，就变得非常困难。事实上，你刚才问到了，美国成年人平均每天花在屏幕上的时间是四个小时，而使用屏幕的儿童和青少年则高达六个小时。哇。是的。这非常温和。我自己也知道这很有挑战性，对每个人来说都是如此。你在书中谈到，世界上的科技巨头会限制他们孩子使用屏幕的时间。那么这说明了什么？是的，我觉得这很迷人。
It's actually what got me so interested in this topic because I think whenever you see that sort of hypocrisy, you've got to ask what's going on. So there's a process in business called dog fooding. And it's basically where if you promote a product as a business person, the best way to show that you think the product is something other people should use and have is by using it yourself, by letting your kids use it. It's a sort of proof that it's a good product. And in most industries, there's a lot of dog fooding. If you work for Coca-Cola, you drink Coca-Cola, your kids drink Coke,
这正是让我对这个话题产生浓厚兴趣的原因，因为我觉得每当你看到这种虚伪时，你就必须问问到底发生了什么。商业中有一个过程叫“吃自己的狗粮”（dogfooding）。基本上，如果你作为一个商人推广一种产品，证明你认为该产品是其他人应该使用和拥有的最好方式，就是你自己使用它，并让你的孩子使用它。这是一种证明它是好产品的证据。在大多数行业，有很多“吃狗粮”的行为。如果你为可口可乐工作，你就喝可口可乐，你的孩子也喝可乐，
all your friends drink Coke and so on. And that's a very basic principle of the business. But that does not happen. There's a huge violation of that, a deviation in the world of screens and tech in particular. So you'll find a lot of the tech titans talking in glowing terms publicly about their products. But when you actually look at the way they interact with those same products and the way their kids interact, there's a huge disjunction where the kids and they themselves are not using the very same products. They will get up on stage and say, your kids should use this product. I think it tells us that the people who know the most about these products are a little bit scared of them.
你所有的朋友都喝可乐，以此类推。这是商业的一个非常基本的原则。但这在屏幕和科技领域并没有发生。在这些领域，存在着巨大的违背和偏差。你会发现很多科技巨头在公开场合用溢美之词谈论他们的产品。但当你真正观察他们与这些产品的互动方式，以及他们孩子与这些产品的互动方式时，会发现巨大的脱节，他们的孩子和他们自己并没有在使用同样的产品。他们会站在台上说，你们的孩子应该使用这个产品。我认为这告诉我们，最了解这些产品的人其实对它们有点害怕。
They're a little bit worried about the fact that even their kids who are generally wealthy from very privileged backgrounds who have all the advantage. in the world are incapable of saying, I will only use this for an hour a day. And if they're worried about that for their own kids, it suggests to me that the rest of us should also be concerned. And that's what pushed me to write the book. And in the book, you wrote about how addictions are largely produced by the environment and circumstances. And at the same time, we hear how genetics do play a role.
他们有点担心，即使是他们的孩子——通常来自非常富裕、享有特权、拥有世界上所有优势的背景——也无法做到“我每天只使用一小时”。如果他们为自己的孩子担心，这对我来说意味着我们其他人也应该感到担忧。这就是促使我写这本书的原因。在书中，你写道，成瘾在很大程度上是由环境和境遇造成的。与此同时，我们也听说遗传学确实起了一定作用。
So can you explain how the environment you're in, the circumstances impact, and create an addiction or make it worse? Yeah. I mean, I think this is the perfect case study that illustrates the point. the fact that just such a massive part of the population today undermines its own well-being and will admit to doing that by using a product much more than intended because it's just in the moment very hard to stop. So there's a lot of debate over the word addiction, whether it should be used to describe this sort of phenomenon. And I'm agnostic about it. I'm happy to use it or not
那么你能解释一下你所处的环境和境遇是如何影响并造成成瘾，或者使成瘾恶化的吗？是的。我认为这是一个完美的案例研究，说明了这一点。事实上，今天很大一部分人口正在损害自己的幸福感，并且会承认这一点，因为他们使用产品的时间远超预期，仅仅是因为在当下很难停下来。关于“成瘾”这个词是否应该用来描述这种现象，有很多争论。我对此持中立态度。我乐意使用它，或者不
use it. But I think the phenomenon itself, when you describe it objectively, is pretty blunt. And it is that almost all of us spend way more time than we think and when we're actually shown how much time we're shocked but struggle to curb our use. And that's true for phones and tablets and all sorts of other screens that are robbing us of a huge part of the day. So, you know, the argument, the old argument was that perhaps there was an addictive personality that some people had and they would seek out drugs or alcohol or nicotine and then they would become addicted. And that there was something very low-level biological about that, that it was an individual difference characteristic. And I think that overstates the role of these individual differences. I think
使用它。但我认为，当你客观地描述这种现象时，它本身是非常直白的。那就是我们几乎所有人花在屏幕上的时间都比我们想象的要多得多，当我们真正看到自己花了多少时间时，我们会感到震惊，但却难以抑制自己的使用。这对于手机、平板电脑和所有其他夺走我们一天大部分时间的屏幕来说都是如此。所以，你知道，旧的论点是，也许有些人有“成瘾性人格”，他们会寻找毒品、酒精或尼古丁，然后就会上瘾。这其中有一些非常低级的生物学因素，即这是一种个体差异特征。我认为这夸大了这些个体差异的作用。我认为
they're there and they're important, but I don't think they play the only role. The way we know that is because if a huge percentage of the population today feels in some way tethered to these devices in a way that they don't want to be, you can't say that everyone has the same personality defect or deficiency, that there's something wrong with all of us. What you have to be have to start to say is obviously there's something about the situation, the circumstance, the environment that we're in. If you put the most irresistible buffet of options in front of us, especially when we're in a world where a lot of people are fairly lonely, there's a fair amount of general unhappiness, we're overwhelmed, most of us live in big cities that
它们存在并且很重要，但我不认为它们起到了唯一的作用。我们知道这一点的原因是，如果今天很大一部分人口在某种程度上感到被这些设备束缚，而他们并不想这样，你不能说每个人都有同样的人格缺陷或不足，不能说我们所有人都有问题。你必须开始说，显然是我们所处的环境、境遇和情况有问题。如果你把最令人无法抗拒的自助餐选项放在我们面前，尤其是在一个很多人相当孤独、普遍存在相当多不快乐、我们感到不知所措的世界里，我们大多数人生活在大城市里，
are fairly impersonal. If you can get some measure of connection by being on a screen, that would attract you initially. But once you get there, if you like a rat in a cage or like a monkey, if you're in front of all of these hooks that are just perfectly designed and have evolved over time to be weaponized and make it very hard for you to stop using those products it's the environment that's driving you there I don't think there's anything special about me that means that when I check my phone at the end of the day I have a tracking app I'm using my phone four hours a day I don't think that's a personality variable that's driving that sort of behavior I think it's really just that I am now part of this particular world this culture this landscape where this is what people do and four hours is the average.
这些城市相当没有人情味。如果你能通过屏幕获得某种程度的连接，你最初会被吸引。但一旦你到了那里，就像笼子里的老鼠或猴子一样，如果你面对的是所有这些经过完美设计、随着时间推移而演变成“武器化”的钩子，让你很难停止使用这些产品，那么是环境在驱动你。我不认为我有什么特别之处，意味着当我一天结束时检查手机，我有一个追踪应用程序，我每天使用手机四个小时，我不认为这是驱动这种行为的人格变量，我认为这真的只是因为我现在是这个特定世界、这种文化、这种景观的一部分，这就是人们所做的，四个小时是平均水平。
I'm not even an outlier. Yeah, absolutely. It seems like such a large chunk of time, but we're always on our phones. I mean, email, tax, social media, whatever it is. Exactly. Browsing the internet and go on forever. Yeah, and not all of it. It's created equal, right?
我甚至不是个异类。是的，绝对是。这看起来是一大块时间，但我们总是拿着手机。我是说，电子邮件、短信、社交媒体，无论是什么。没错。浏览互联网，没完没了。是的，并非所有这些都是平等的，对吧？
Obviously, using the phone as a utility as a map as a way to work out what the weather's doing for boarding passes when you travel, things like that. I think that's actually very enriching because it takes a mundane task and it makes it tractable and it means you spend less. time on that task and that frees up other time, other chunks of time for other things, which I think it's great. And I think that's the very best use of technology like phones, a sort of digital Swiss army knife. Having said that, so much of what we do is not utilitarian in that sense, and it is kind of hollow. And when we do that for a long time, we don't feel good
显然，将手机作为一种工具，作为地图，作为一种查看天气、旅行时查看登机牌的方式，诸如此类。我认为这实际上是非常丰富的，因为它把一件平凡的任务变得易于处理，意味着你花在那个任务上的时间更少，这腾出了其他时间，其他大块的时间去做别的事情，我认为这很好。我认为这是像手机这样的技术最好的用途，一种数字瑞士军刀。话虽如此，我们所做的很多事情在那种意义上并不是功利性的，而且有点空洞。当我们长时间这样做时，我们大多数时候对自己感觉并不好。
about ourselves most of the time. You spoke about how our humanity really lives in those free hours, those three moments. What is it doing to our humanity if we're spending all our time probably doing something that's not so productive and beneficial on our screen? Yeah, I mean, I think it's hard to argue that personal contact is not important. I think it obviously is very important to us. Face-to-face time is important, especially for younger people who are developing social skills. You know, if a lot of that rests on trial and error and getting feedback as you behave and seeing how people respond to you, you need to do that in real time and you need that feedback to be high fidelity across all the channels and it needs to be
你谈到我们的人性真正存在于那些自由的时间、那些自由的时刻。如果我们把所有时间都花在屏幕上做一些可能并不那么富有成效和有益的事情，这对我们的人性意味着什么？是的，我的意思是，很难争辩说个人接触不重要。我认为这对我们显然非常重要。面对面的时间很重要，尤其是对于正在发展社交技能的年轻人来说。你知道，如果很多社交能力依赖于试错，依赖于你在行为时获得反馈并观察人们如何回应你，你需要实时进行，并且你需要这种反馈在所有渠道上都是高保真的，而且它需要
quick and rapid. So if you're a kid who's a couple of years old and you take someone else's toy, you need to know instantly that that makes that kid cry, their face scrunches up, you see tears, and if you're a normal person, you feel bad about that and you don't keep doing it. So that's how kids learn. Also, if you get bopped on the head because you've done that, you learn that way as well. But if most of your learning happens behind a screen, the feedback is very fun. It takes a long time to reach you if it ever reaches you at all. And that's one reason why it's so easy to bully people when they're behind a screen. You just need to look at YouTube comments or comments on faceless anonymous sites where people have usernames.
快速、迅速。所以，如果你是一个两岁左右的孩子，你拿了别人的玩具，你需要立刻知道这会让那个孩子哭，他们的脸会皱起来，你看到眼泪，如果你是一个正常人，你会为此感到难过，你就不会继续这样做了。这就是孩子们学习的方式。此外，如果你因为这样做而被打了一下头，你也会通过那种方式学习。但如果你的大部分学习都发生在屏幕后面，反馈是非常有趣的。它需要很长时间才能传达给你，如果它真的能传达给你的话。这就是为什么在屏幕后面欺负人如此容易的一个原因。你只需要看看 YouTube 的评论，或者在人们有用户名的无脸匿名网站上的评论。
It's very easy to be cruel if you don't see the effects of that cruelty. And we don't have to see that if we're dealing behind screens all the time. So I think that's a big part of it. It makes it easy to be callous. So the worst version of yourself is allowed to flourish. and I think for kids they never learn to be fully adapted, fully evolved social creatures because they don't get to try these different things out, they don't get to hone their skills. I mean, you know, if you're sick from work or school for a week and you go back, that first day,
如果你看不到这种残忍的影响，就很容易变得残忍。如果我们一直通过屏幕交流，我们就不必看到这一点。所以我认为这是很大一部分原因。这让人很容易变得冷酷无情。所以你最糟糕的一面被允许滋生。我认为对于孩子们来说，他们永远学不会成为完全适应、完全进化的社会生物，因为他们没有机会尝试这些不同的事情，他们没有机会磨练自己的技能。我的意思是，你知道，如果你因为生病而请假一周，回去工作或上学，那第一天，
everything feels a little clunky, it's a little awkward. And being a capable social being takes work and time and effort and feedback. And we don't always notice that's going on, but it's with us all the time. as we're behaving. And so if you remove that or you make it much fuzzier, make the feedback hard to perceive, I think you're always going to make people less capable as beings in this world. We don't know what that actually means for young kids. So we know that the digital natives, the true digital natives in the iPhone era now 10 years old, 11 years old, they aren't even teens yet, or tweens. They aren't adolescents. They don't have kids. They are not adults. They don't
一切都感觉有点笨拙，有点尴尬。成为一个有能力的社会人需要工作、时间和努力以及反馈。我们并不总是注意到这一点正在发生，但它在我们行为时一直伴随着我们。所以如果你删除了这一点，或者让它变得模糊得多，让反馈难以察觉，我认为你总是会让人在这个世界上变得能力不足。我们不知道这对年幼的孩子来说意味着什么。所以我们知道，数字原住民，iPhone 时代的真正数字原住民，现在 10 岁、11 岁，他们甚至还不是青少年，或者青春期前。他们不是青少年。他们没有孩子。他们不是成年人。他们没有
have jobs. We have no idea whether this generation will in some sense look different from previous generations because they've spent all this time on screens. It's something that we will know more about in the next 10, 15, 20 years. But in the meantime, I think it's worth being cautious. So how do we live in this modern world and not get addicted to our screens? I think, you know, the one very extreme approach is to say, well, either you use them or you don't. So let's go cold turkey. And I think that's ridiculous. I think partly because it's just very difficult, you You create a very difficult life for yourself. I've had maybe five or ten people email me over the last, I guess, two years and say,
工作。我们根本不知道这一代人是否会在某种意义上看起来与前几代人不同，因为他们把所有时间都花在了屏幕上。这是我们在未来 10、15、20 年里会了解更多的事情。但在此期间，我认为值得保持谨慎。那么我们如何生活在这个现代世界中而不对屏幕上瘾呢？我认为，你知道，一种非常极端的方法是说，要么你使用它们，要么你不使用。所以让我们彻底戒断。我认为这很荒谬。我认为部分原因是这非常困难，你
I don't use any tech. Excuse me. I don't use any form of technology. My first response is, well, you're using email to tell me that. But even if that's the only time you've used tech, their whole lives are defined by this tendency to just avoid technology altogether. I think it's a really uphill battle. So I wouldn't say cold turkey is the way to go.
会为自己创造一种非常艰难的生活。在过去，我想是两年里，可能有五到十个人给我发电子邮件说，我不使用任何科技产品。抱歉。我不使用任何形式的科技产品。我的第一反应是，好吧，你正在使用电子邮件告诉我这一点。但即使那是你唯一一次使用科技产品，他们的整个人生也被这种完全避免科技的倾向所定义。我认为这是一场非常艰难的战斗。所以我不会说彻底戒断是可行之道。
I think the more important thing is to try to set up structures that limit your usage. So one thing to do is to, for example, pick a time of day, a couple of hours in the afternoon or the evening or dinner time or some sacred time in the day. I try to make Saturdays wherever possible days where I have my phone on airplane mode. So I can use it as a camera if I'm out with the kids and my wife. But I don't use my phone as a phone. And so it's really about setting up structures and habits that act against this tendency to just mindlessly reach for your phone.
我认为更重要的事情是尝试建立限制你使用的结构。所以可以做的一件事是，例如，选择一天中的某个时间，下午或晚上的几个小时，或者晚餐时间，或者一天中某个神圣的时间。我尽量让周六尽可能成为我手机处于飞行模式的日子。这样如果我和孩子们以及妻子外出，我可以用它作为相机。但我不用手机作为电话。所以这真的是关于建立对抗这种盲目伸手拿手机倾向的结构和习惯。
The best thing we can do is not have to exert willpower. You know, if you have to do that afresh every time and make that new decision every time, it's exhausting. So the better thing to do is to say, for example, I have a drawer in my room, I will put my phone in my drawer for this number of hours every single day, that'll be my habit. Once I've done that, I can't reach for my phone mindlessly because it's far away. and then I get about doing whatever else I need to do in the day. And I've spoken to a lot of people who've done it and it works for them.
我们能做的最好的事情就是不必动用意志力。你知道，如果你每次都必须重新开始，每次都必须做出那个新的决定，那会让人筋疲力尽。所以更好的做法是说，例如，我的房间里有一个抽屉，我每天会把手机放进抽屉里几个小时，那将是我的习惯。一旦我这样做了，我就不能盲目地伸手去拿手机，因为它离我很远。然后我就去做一天中我需要做的任何其他事情。我和很多这样做过的人谈过，这对他们很有效。
They don't feel like they have to give up using phones completely, but they know there is part of the day that is preserved and kind of sacred for time in nature, outdoors, doing all sorts of other really important things. So it's really just a matter of being mindful about our usage. And the first step for everyone, I think, is getting a tracking app to see how long you think you're spending. We're really bad at intuiting that. I've asked a lot of people this.
他们并不觉得必须完全放弃使用手机，但他们知道一天中有一部分时间是保留下来的，是神圣的，用于亲近自然、户外活动、做各种其他真正重要的事情。所以这真的只是关于对我们的使用保持正念的问题。我认为对每个人来说，第一步是获取一个追踪应用程序，看看你认为自己花了多少时间。我们真的不擅长直觉判断这一点。我问过很多人。
And the guy who created the tracking app I use asks a lot of people as well. And people routinely underestimate by half. So they tend to say an hour and a half maybe, and the truth is for most people, it's between three and six hours a day, which is staggering. And lately, Facebook and social media sites
我使用的追踪应用程序的创建者也问过很多人。人们通常会低估一半。所以他们倾向于说可能一个半小时，而事实是对于大多数人来说，每天是三到六个小时，这令人震惊。最近，Facebook 和社交媒体网站
and tech executives have come out to say they want to help be a part of, part of the solution and to find ways to tell people to signal they've, how long they've used, or maybe they're using too much. Can you talk a little bit more about that? For a business, does that go against their interests to be telling people, no, don't spend as much time on our screens? Like, how does a company balance that?
以及科技高管们出来说，他们想帮助成为解决方案的一部分，并找到方法告诉人们，发出信号，告诉他们使用了多久，或者也许他们使用得太多了。你能多谈谈这一点吗？对于一家企业来说，告诉人们“不，不要在我们的屏幕上花那么多时间”是否违背了他们的利益？一家公司如何平衡这一点？
And is that going to be effective? It's a good question. I mean, I think the question of whether it's consistent with making lots and lots of money is an important one. I think for a lot of companies, they need to be long term in the way they think about that question. So today you could make money by exploiting everyone who uses your product and making sure they use it for as long as possible So advertising dollars just pour in But by five years from now there might be another product that comes out that does what you do, but it does it in a way that's actually friendly to consumers
这会有效吗？这是一个好问题。我的意思是，我认为这是否与赚取大量金钱相一致是一个重要的问题。我认为对于很多公司来说，他们在思考这个问题时需要着眼于长远。所以今天你可以通过剥削每一个使用你产品的人并确保他们尽可能长时间地使用它来赚钱，这样广告费就会滚滚而来。但五年后，可能会有另一种产品出现，它做着你做的事情，但它以一种对消费者真正友好的方式来做。
So that's one thing is you can start to compete on that dimension You can be the better company that actually cares about its consumers and you start to steal money away from the companies that are not caring Also, you know we see this in lots of areas of business if you think about industrial companies that would like to be able to just dump pollutants into the waters, into the waterways, into the air, it's cheapest to do that, to use fuels that are cheapest, that are very dirty, to dump pollutants. That's the easiest way to get rid of industrial waste. Companies can't do that anymore, either because there's been a top-down influence from the government that says you can't do this anymore, it's legislated against, or because there's enough grassroots support from people
所以这是一件事，你可以开始在那个维度上竞争。你可以成为真正关心消费者的更好的公司，你开始从那些不关心的公司那里抢走钱。此外，你知道我们在商业的许多领域都看到了这一点，如果你想到那些希望能够直接向水道、空气中倾倒污染物的工业公司，这样做最便宜，使用最便宜、非常肮脏的燃料，倾倒污染物。这是处理工业废料最简单的方法。公司现在不能再这样做了，要么是因为政府有自上而下的影响，说你不能再这样做了，这是立法禁止的，要么是因为有来自人们的足够的草根支持，
who boycott the company. One problem with these tech companies is they are all individually monopolies in their own way where there is no substitute for Facebook or for Instagram or for Twitter or for Snapchat they are unique in some sense and it's these are markets where one player wins all and they have all won in these markets at least for now so if we say we won't use you they don't take that all that seriously but if there's enough pressure as there has been a lot of grassroots pressure and there's starting to be pressure around the world from governments as well these companies are forced to act in ways that are not
他们抵制这家公司。这些科技公司的一个问题是，它们在各自的方式上都是垄断者，没有 Facebook、Instagram、Twitter 或 Snapchat 的替代品，它们在某种意义上是独一无二的，这些市场是一个赢家通吃的市场，至少目前它们都在这些市场中赢了。所以如果我们说我们不会使用你，他们并不太认真对待。但如果有足够的压力，就像已经有很多草根压力一样，而且世界各地的政府也开始施加压力，这些公司被迫以不
always in their best interest as businesses, but that ultimately will probably ensure their preservation as organizations, companies, platforms in the longer run. So it's a complicated, it's a complicated situation for them, but I think they've all been pushed into a situation where they have to be seen. I'm not sure they're all doing what they have to do, but they have to be seen to be responding. And there aren't many companies of the big ones now that aren't doing at least something to pay, at least lip service to the idea that they need to be more thoughtful about their consumers. If I can just give you an example though what I mean by that because it's to say it's lip services is I think fairly provocative but I believe a lot of the
总是符合它们作为企业最佳利益的方式行事，但最终这可能会确保它们作为组织、公司、平台在长远来看的生存。所以这对它们来说是一个复杂的情况，但我认为它们都被推到了一个必须被看到的境地。我不确定它们是否都在做它们必须做的事情，但它们必须被看到是在做出回应。现在大公司中没有几家不做点什么来至少对它们需要更体贴消费者这一想法表示口头支持。不过，如果我能给你举个例子，说明我的意思，因为我认为说这是口头支持相当具有挑衅性，但我相信很多
companies are doing that. So one example is so with Instagram now what they do is if you have seen all the posts that were posted by the people you follow in the last two days a little pop-up says you have got to the end of all the posts you basically don't need to be on Instagram right now. Problem is if you follow hundreds or thousands of people, that's thousands and thousands of posts and it becomes a goal. So what is seen to be a stopping queue, it's a point that says you should stop using this is actually something people seek out now. So they will spend more time on the platform trying to see everything because now they know if they don't see everything, there's a marker that will tell them when they get there.
公司都在那样做。所以一个例子是，Instagram 现在所做的是，如果你已经看到了你关注的人在过去两天发布的所有帖子，一个小弹窗会说你已经看到了所有帖子的结尾，你基本上现在不需要在 Instagram 上了。问题是，如果你关注了数百或数千人，那就是成千上万的帖子，这变成了一个目标。所以被视为停止队列的东西，即一个告诉你应该停止使用的点，现在实际上是人们追求的东西。所以他们会花更多时间在平台上试图看完所有内容，因为现在他们知道如果不看完，有一个标记会告诉他们什么时候到达那里。
And so it's sort of undermining. Basically, if you're going to stop people from using the product or encourage them to get off, don't make an unattainable goal the point at which you say, okay, now it's time for you to get off. So that's one example that I don't think is very effective. Do you think businesses should take it upon themselves to tell their employees, okay, after 6pm, don't check your work email? Should companies do that? Yeah, I think so. I think this is a different case because for, excuse me, for tech companies, it might undermine their profit. But for organizations that say don't use, or you don't have to use or we won't send or release emails after a certain time.
所以这有点破坏性。基本上，如果你要阻止人们使用产品或鼓励他们离开，不要把一个无法实现的目标作为你说的“好吧，现在是你离开的时候了”的点。所以这是一个我认为不太有效的例子。你认为企业应该主动告诉员工，好吧，下午 6 点以后，不要检查工作邮件吗？公司应该这样做吗？是的，我认为应该。我认为这是一个不同的情况，因为对于科技公司来说，这可能会破坏它们的利润。但对于那些说“不要使用”或者“我们不会在特定时间之后发送或发布电子邮件”的组织来说。
That's actually really good for employee productivity, for employee well-being, for long-term retention. There are companies now, there are few companies that protect people when they're on vacation from their emails. So they will suspend email accounts where you cannot possibly get any new emails and when you get back to work at the end of your vacation,
这对员工生产力、员工幸福感、长期留任实际上真的很好。现在有一些公司，有少数公司在员工度假时保护他们免受电子邮件的干扰。所以他们会暂停电子邮件账户，你根本无法收到任何新邮件，当你度假结束回到工作岗位时，
your inbox looks exactly the way it did when you left, which is great. People actually do go on vacation and they disconnect. And that's a huge competitive advantage for those companies. There are people who will seek out jobs at those companies over other equally good companies in other respects because they know this this company cares about me and these employees tend to stick around for longer they don't burn out as easily. So I think there's really good reason for companies to introduce policies
你的收件箱看起来和你离开时一模一样，这太棒了。人们确实去度假并断开了连接。这对那些公司来说是一个巨大的竞争优势。有些人会选择在这些公司工作，而不是在其他方面同样好的公司，因为他们知道这家公司关心我，而且这些员工倾向于留任更长时间，他们不容易精疲力竭。所以我认为公司引入政策确实有很好的理由
like these. There are cases where it's difficult. So if you're in a market that's run globally 24 hours a day, if you work with stock markets for example, you can't really have people not respond, but there are still things you can do. You could at least explain to them that you recognize this as a big drain on them, maybe say to all employees, we're giving you sort of shifts. So your shift means that you will not be getting emailed at these times and you will co-work with someone who will get the emails at that time or some structure. There's always something that can be done. It's just a matter of being driven and motivated to do it.
像这样的政策。有些情况下这很困难。所以如果你在一个 24 小时全球运行的市场中，例如如果你与股票市场合作，你不能真的让人们不回应，但仍然有一些事情你可以做。你至少可以向他们解释，你认识到这对他们来说是一个巨大的消耗，也许对所有员工说，我们给你提供轮班。所以你的轮班意味着你不会在这些时间收到电子邮件，你将与一个会在那个时间收到电子邮件的人共同工作，或者某种结构。总有一些事情是可以做的。这只是关于是否有动力和动机去做的问题。
And I think a lot more organizations are starting to think about it now. And what should parents do? I mean, we hear all the time how children screen time should be limited yet. you know, same time there's a lot of deems and things they can do on there or, you know, exploring the internet or something like that. So what advice do you have for parents? Well, parents, you know, they teach their kids all sorts of things. They teach their kids oral hygiene, dental hygiene. They teach them how to brush their teeth. They teach them how to interact. They teach them manners. I think one of the things parents and schools should teach kids is sort
而且我认为现在有更多的组织开始考虑这个问题了。父母应该怎么做？我的意思是，我们一直听说孩子使用屏幕的时间应该受到限制，然而，同时，他们可以在上面做很多事情，或者探索互联网之类的。所以你对父母有什么建议？嗯，父母，你知道，他们教孩子各种各样的东西。他们教孩子口腔卫生、牙齿卫生。他们教他们如何刷牙。他们教他们如何互动。他们教他们礼貌。我认为父母和学校应该教孩子的一种东西是某种
of technological hygiene. How do you interact in the world with screens? How do you act in a way that is good for you, good for the people you're interacting with, that maintains your integrity, that means you have time for other things. That's not being taught, but I think it's a really critical new life skill that we didn't have to worry about 20 years ago. So part of it is actually actively educating kids about screens the way we do all the traditional topics that we've focused on for, I don't know, hundreds of years. So that's part of it. But then the question of how you actually regulate how much time parents, how much time your kids are spending on screens is really difficult one. It's easy when they're younger or easier when they're younger. I have a two-year-old
技术卫生。你如何在屏幕世界中互动？你如何以一种对自己好、对你互动的人好、保持你的正直、意味着你有时间做其他事情的方式行事？这没有被教导，但我认为这是一个非常关键的新生活技能，我们在 20 年前不必担心。所以部分原因是实际上积极地教育孩子关于屏幕的知识，就像我们对待我们已经关注了，我不知道，几百年的所有传统主题一样。所以这是部分原因。但随后关于你如何实际调节你的孩子在屏幕上花费多少时间的问题是一个非常困难的问题。当他们年轻时很容易，或者当他们年轻时更容易。我有一个两岁
and a one-year-old and at least with my first, my first kid, my son, because he was my only kid at that time, I could manage how much time he spent in front of screens and for 18 months he didn't see a screen. But then my daughter came along and so now that my son watches TV, from birth she watched TV because if he's watching it, she's going to see it as well. And so it becomes very tricky. I used to be very hard line about this. And I think once you start, experiencing it as a parent you realize it's much more tricky than you think so the issue is I think again it's the same that you would do for yourself which is to say these hours are tech-free and I'm always very vocal and verbal with them about the
和一个一岁的孩子，至少对于我的第一个孩子，我的儿子，因为他当时是我唯一的孩子，我可以管理他花在屏幕前的时间，18 个月里他没有看到屏幕。但后来我的女儿出生了，所以现在我的儿子看电视，从出生起她就看电视，因为如果他在看，她也会看到。所以这变得非常棘手。我过去对这一点非常强硬。而且我认为一旦你作为父母开始体验它，你就会意识到它比你想象的要棘手得多。所以问题是，我认为同样，这和你自己要做的事情是一样的，那就是说这些小时是无科技的，我总是非常直言不讳地告诉他们，
fact that this is we're gonna watch one episode of Sesame Street and then we're done and I understand that they know they get a sort of dose and once the dose is finished it's done for the day so there's that I think it gets much trickier when you talk about teens and adolescents and it's partly because they are choosing between being isolated from their friends and engaging with their friends because so much of what goes on socially goes on online for a lot of them. But again, it's really a matter of having a conversation about, as I said before, sort of technological hygiene about balance, about the fact that we can't always eat dessert,
事实上，我们要看一集《芝麻街》，然后我们就结束了，我知道他们知道他们得到了一种剂量，一旦剂量结束，这一天就结束了。所以有那个，我认为当你谈论青少年和青春期前时，它变得棘手得多，部分原因是他们在与朋友隔离和与朋友互动之间做出选择，因为对他们中的许多人来说，社交中发生的大部分事情都在网上发生。但同样，这真的是关于进行对话，正如我之前所说，关于某种技术卫生，关于平衡，关于我们不能总是吃甜点，
we can't always spend our time playing and not being at school or working. The same is true with screens. Screens are fun and you get access to your friends and that's great, but there's got to be time for other things. So it's just a matter of having this general discussion about balance. And then there's a small percentage of kids for whom those measures don't work. Setting boundaries doesn't work. And at least the stats that I've seen suggest that between 1% of the population of teens has a significant enough problem that they probably need some sort of counseling or therapy about that issue.
我们不能总是花时间玩耍而不去上学或工作。屏幕也是如此。屏幕很有趣，你可以接触到你的朋友，这很好，但必须有时间做其他事情。所以这只是关于进行这种关于平衡的普遍讨论。然后有一小部分孩子，这些措施对他们不起作用。设定界限不起作用。至少我看到的统计数据表明，1% 的青少年人口有足够严重的问题，他们可能需要某种关于该问题的咨询或治疗。
So at that point, if there's an ongoing struggle, and I'm sure that number's growing now, it's probably worth talking to a therapist. And a lot of psychologists and therapists now deal with this all the time, whether they want to or not, because it's such a huge part of what goes on. One of my very good friends in Australia is a psychologist, and he told me that a few years ago he started noticing that he would hear from a, he mainly treats teens.
所以在那一点上，如果存在持续的斗争，我相信这个数字现在正在增长，那么和治疗师谈谈可能是值得的。现在很多心理学家和治疗师一直在处理这个问题，无论他们是否愿意，因为它是发生的事情中非常巨大的一部分。我在澳大利亚的一位非常好的朋友是一位心理学家，他告诉我，几年前他开始注意到他会听到一个，他主要治疗青少年。
He said he started to hear from these teens that they would describe a long conversation and it would go on for maybe half an hour, and then it would suddenly dawn on him that this whole thing happened. behind a screen and it was all text. But the way they described it was as though it was face to face. So even that means that psychologists, therapists,
他说他开始从这些青少年那里听到，他们会描述一段很长的对话，可能会持续半小时，然后他会突然意识到这一切都发生在屏幕后面，而且全是文字。但他们描述它的方式就好像是面对面的一样。所以即使这意味着心理学家、治疗师
need to now navigate a very different situation from what they had to before and to understand that it's not always clear the way people interact now, whether it's through one modality or another, you actually have to establish that explicitly up front because young people now sort of think of them as interchangeable in some sense. And I think that's also a huge problem. You also have talked about how we've not reached the peak of tech. There will be new technologies, new social media outlets coming out in the future.
现在需要导航一种与以前完全不同的情况，并理解人们现在的互动方式并不总是很清楚，无论是通过一种方式还是另一种方式，你实际上必须预先明确地建立这一点，因为现在的年轻人某种意义上认为它们是可以互换的。我认为这也是一个巨大的问题。你还谈到我们还没有达到科技的顶峰。未来会有新的技术、新的社交媒体渠道出现。
So how do we prepare for that? I mean, it's already, our addiction to screens is already pretty bad. It's pretty bad, yeah. So how do we have to be here for the onslaught of what's coming? Yeah, and I think that's why it's so important to consider this issue now before it gets worse. I think there's a tendency in pretty much any, any market, any landscape to believe you've reached a destination. So we think, oh, this is crazy. We're in this world where 15 years ago there was nothing.
那么我们如何为此做准备呢？我的意思是，它已经，我们对屏幕的成瘾已经相当严重了。相当严重，是的。所以我们如何为即将到来的冲击做好准备？是的，我认为这就是为什么在情况变得更糟之前考虑这个问题如此重要。我认为在几乎任何市场、任何景观中都有一种倾向，认为你已经到达了目的地。所以我们想，哦，这太疯狂了。我们处于这样一个世界，15 年前什么都没有，
like what we have now and Facebook and Twitter and Instagram and Snapchat and so on feel feel like fixtures today but in 10 years when we look back at them I'm sure not all of them will exist in the form they're in today some of them will have been marginalized even Facebook is marginalized now by teams so things are going to change a lot and there's going to be new stuff that we don't even imagine or can't even imagine yet and one thing we can imagine is virtual and augmented reality and that's going to be a much bigger consumer product than it is now You talk to people in that industry, the forecasts are that within 10 years, an industry that is now worth about one to two billion dollars will be worth a hundred or more billion dollars and that most of us, just as we walk around with phones, will have some form of goggle, very portable goggle that will take with us.
像我们现在拥有的这样，Facebook、Twitter、Instagram、Snapchat 等等今天感觉像是固定装置，但在 10 年后当我们回顾它们时，我相信它们不会都以今天这样的形式存在，其中一些甚至会被青少年边缘化，所以事情会发生很大变化，会有我们甚至无法想象或还无法想象的新东西，我们可以想象的一件事是虚拟和增强现实，那将是一个比现在大得多的消费产品。你和那个行业的人交谈，预测是 10 年内，一个现在价值约 10 到 20 亿美元的行业将价值 1000 亿或更多，我们大多数人，就像我们带着手机走来走去一样，都会有某种护目镜，非常便携的护目镜，我们会随身携带。
And so if at any moment in time, you can check out of the real world and go into this perfect virtual world that is exactly what you want. Why wouldn't you do that? As humans, we seek pleasure. That seems like a pretty good fun thing to be doing. We already do it with our phones. It's going to be so much harder to resist when it's a virtual world that feels really compelling. And if phones take us out of the here and now, at least we can still sort of respond to other people. But if you're actually not in this world, you're behind a screen or behind goggles,
因此，如果任何时候你都可以脱离现实世界，进入这个完全符合你心意的完美虚拟世界，你为什么不这样做呢？作为人类，我们追求快乐。这听起来是一件非常有趣的事情。我们已经在手机上这样做了。当虚拟世界变得非常引人入胜时，我们将更难抵御这种诱惑。如果说手机让我们脱离了当下，至少我们还能以某种方式回应他人。但如果你实际上并不在这个世界，而是躲在屏幕或护目镜后面，
it's going to be really hard for us to engage with each other in the real world. So like you said, we're having these conversations now and in such a broad sense. I think so, yeah. There'll be a lot of more challenges coming in the future. Yeah. Well, thank you so much for joining. Thanks for having me. Thank you.
我们将很难在现实世界中与彼此互动。所以正如你所说，我们现在正在进行这些对话，意义非常广泛。我想是的。未来会有更多挑战。是的。非常感谢你的加入。谢谢你的邀请。谢谢。
Speaking of Psychology is part of the APA podcast network, which includes other great podcasts like APA journals dialogue about the latest and most exciting psychological research and progress notes about the practice of psychology. You can find our podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also visit speakingof psychology.org to view more episodes and to find resources on the topics we discuss. I'm your host, Caitlin Luna, for the American Psychological Association. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《心理学访谈》是美国心理学会（APA）播客网络的一部分，该网络还包括其他优秀的播客，如探讨最新、最令人兴奋的心理学研究的《APA期刊对话》，以及关于心理学实践的《进度笔记》。你可以在iTunes、Stitcher或任何你获取播客的地方找到我们的节目。你也可以访问speakingofpsychology.org查看更多剧集，并查找我们所讨论主题的相关资源。我是主持人凯特琳·卢纳，代表美国心理学会。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。